el congreso de nueva york- planta cara a
la corte suprema de eeuu los
legisladores del estado aprobaron una
legislación para limitar ampliamente el
porte de armas en lugares públicos lo
hace una semana después de que el alto
tribunal anulara la ley de nueva york
que imponía restricciones al porte de
armas fuera del hogar me niego como dije
desde el primer día a renunciar a mi
derecho como gobernadora de proteger a
los neoyorquinos de la violencia armada
o de cualquier otra forma de daño la
medida convertiría en un delito grave
portar armas en diversos espacios
públicos como las escuelas los
tribunales los edificios gubernamentales
o el transporte público entre otros la
normativa hará obligatorio un curso de
seguridad y capacitación de tiro para
quienes opten a tener un permiso de
armas de fuego el fuego es final
fráncfort que la corte suprema de eeuu
transmita esta decisión a nueva york- en
este momento en que las armas ilegales
han estado inundando las calles y la
violencia armada está en su punto más
alto es absolutamente despreciable
el congreso neoyorquino también aprobó
una enmienda que abriría camino a que el
derecho al aborto quede consagrado en la
constitución estatal una medida que
también está claramente en contra de la
decisión de la corte suprema de anular
la histórica sentencia de 1973 roe
versus wade que garantizaba el acceso al
aborto como un derecho constitucional en
todo eeuu